so and Pepe will be playing white every
game
okay
all right hi everybody sorry we had some
technical difficulties and we will be
continuing on from here
so wouldn't I'm Tony Chen from the
sailor's chess club along with me is
pepe cuenca grandmaster in residence he
will be playing blindfold blitz and he's
gonna be bantering along with it with us
as well
filling in to move for Pepe is we have
Kaleb Gosselin to my right and he will
be playing peri one of the truss
associates here than the signals chess
club and it's gonna be a fun time paper
is gonna be playing white day every game
and hopefully somebody will be able to
take him down fingers crossed we'll see
all right so have a please go on please
yes put your blindfold on and we're
ready to start
cd4
six up g5
six Queen d2
long castle
age 4
so far pretty exciting game one of my
job is one of my job's is to distract
Pepe so we'll see if we can get Perry an
advantage here
92 b5
maybe 595
Queen b6
Knight c3
Bishop d7
Bishop III
Queen c7 every Rick a to be a
night b5
dressing McQueen
queen c8
night xt6
Bishop takes d6
rook D 8b 6 okay I think it looks like
our firm very Perry's up a piece and
we'll see how long he can keep that up
so queen
[Music]
g3
and up a piece and still thinking hard
on this and
Knight f6 which takes d8
Queen takes da Queen d6
Perry is now hitting himself for being
other piece and stoic still hard to win
that's an illegal move sorry oh there
was a illegal move by Perry Wow Wow he
played 96 that was a good move eight-six
okay
d4 do what no g4 magic night that's so
bad I can't move that nerves are getting
to them teenage seven teen 87 then g5
straight maybe was to Train Bishop e8 e8
walking
quint xdh ripped xt8
i takes the a G takes f 6 g f6 Bishop e2
knight c6
Knight d4 94 truck tech see for I just
blunder be five rub d8 we get it Perry
yeah it's tough
Bishop c6 b5
Group d6
Bishop b7 Bishop b5
kingi 6a for
each 585 peri-peri is getting palm
pushed on the ship six man you're gonna
have to sack that King g7 a7 Bishop b7
and there's a resonation from Paree in
the game is over that was a good game to
start off I blunder so bad with my mind
I was thinking that you said before II 6
into a 6 so but then I realized that it
was a six Grand Master's well ladies and
gentlemen I don't know this is the
Frizzle the first time I've seen it but
we have one of the top brass here at
stainless Perry anyway so you're in the
we have a one of the top brass here the
st. Louis Chess Club
Tony rich the executive director you
want to say a few words before you begin
Tony oh sure first of all I'd like to
take you know every so everybody's
hoping that they don't blunder we'll see
if that happens
ok we can go ahead and start anytime you
know again you're playing white let's
let's play a 4 again c5 c6 d 4th CD 4
will you text me for not at 6 shall be 5
a 6e 5
tv5 ef6
EF six
short castle
knight c6 rukia one check my minute f6
is gonna hang after others too
are we gonna see a really early
resonation here is that what's gonna
ninety-seven
when f6
Brook g8
Knight to g5
it hurts and we have a groan from Tony
enriched as he enters a difficult
position here Wow Knight e4
Wow Wow just the threat just keep on
coming
so aside from now how was your day today
Tony great up until now right queen a5
is like whenever I talk and try to
interact with the the audience then I
just drop all my pieces at least this
time I haven't dropped them yet
King d8 run away
is this like one of those Morphy games
we're just all your pieces get pin
Queen a6
now let's break the break the
concentration
can't move anything good
g5
only takes f7 check
see I planned on rook f7 but I miss
bishop that fate hangs at the end of all
this nonsense - it looks like kbase
pieces are all up in your face down on
time down on position you can't even see
the board man that's not fair
that's the time here we've got two ten
he's got 246 down on position time yeah
that's my trust game right happens
kingi eight
96 check
okay and there's a resignation from Tony
rich and we have another one down T rich
how do you how do you feel how do you
feel about that game okay so the
accelerated dragon or the
hyperaccelerated dragon like I played it
these Queen d4 lines are really tricky
for me I remember I play been fine gold
in a lot of games in these same lines
and I play Knight f6
'if I've Knight g8e six Knight f6 and I
don't know if it's any good or not but
like that's what I would always play
this good but the case not to take on f6
but you have to close the position with
a six season I thought e six I'm gonna
have a hard time developing my dark
squared Bishop yeah but also have six
Sangin at the same times yeah yeah so
that's the best line for black day I
thought at some point I'd have like rook
a six as an idea to 796 maybe I can sack
the exchange but I found a way to make
that work either it's still slow maybe
yeah well there you have it
end of game to end of opponent - and now
next up we have Kyle Weber Scholastic
Manager here at the st. Louis chess club
he will be victim number three I was
gonna go ahead and pre priest they say
that victim number three all right they
lie to you you had the black pieces so
you prepared wrong let's face facts all
right let's start Game three Pepe
Bishop g5 Bishop b4 b5 h6
Bishop III Bishop takes c3 check B take
C 394 c5
classic break classic break with c5 and
then now distract you a little bit of
course what's uh any anything you want
to say about about schools going on
right now school programs learning chess
it's amazing Queen a5 check c3 and she
all saw that was an almost heee legal
move and Knight takes c3
as the kids say a nowadays pin in to win
it that's how we're doing it
while Kyle's sinking always want to want
to give a shout-out to our man in the
back
Danny Machuca he's the one that makes
everything
production-wise happened when it comes
to our streams so well hats off to you
my friend man Kyle is just thinking like
crazy here I thought those were that
those were the exact words that Tony
Burbridge had I can't do anything I'm
gonna save my queen at least 96 93
castles
we should be too
Bishop d7 Castle 97
don't worry Kyle down down a piece is
gonna against the Grandmaster is not not
desk area you get your good good do it
all right Pepe is getting a lot of
ground looks out rook a to c8
not be 5
all right three minutes left for Pepe
two and a half for Kyle take c1 check
take c1 Queen takes D - Kyle thought he
had that for free
nope Bishop takes me five we should take
me five night at five
rook c7
a six
Bishop d3
Knight takes d4
Bishop III
knight c6
d for Bishop d2
I thought he had a plan he didn't he
didn't he didn't yeah he was trying to
he was trying to push some pawns well
you know his knights you already down
the piece why don't you can go go down -
sure just go for it what's it right not
going anywhere
rook could be eight it shall be for
ninety-eight
Dean of King he 585
right and peppers can you starting to
make his March up to up with the board
it looks like moving all the pieces to
it f5
GF 657
night f7e five
Kyle's Kyle's heartbroken from losing
that pond that was his like one of his
lonely hopes there yeah for d5 pennant
to win in this entire learning that
lesson I cook up a couple of times today
are you gonna try to make a draw offer
to salvage something and there is a time
and that is victim number three I called
it that was pretty pretty awesome maybe
let's before you do that let's uh how do
you feel about that game pretty terrible
alright and there you have a pretty
terrible um that was victim number three
and he is one of the Scott's and
managers here the single is chess club
Kyle Webber thank you very much for
joining us
yep yeah go ahead and send victim number
four I'm gonna pre call it again and we
have a nikkie yep perfect perfect
alright we have Nick risco joining us he
is also a staff member here at the same
most Chess Club you've seen him on many
streams nowadays classes play the people
he does it all he is an average chess
player we are just waiting on our fellow
mover Caleb Gosselin he had to you know
it's a it's a long show so everybody
needs a little break from now and then
alright and here he comes here he comes
okay Nick any any words you want to say
to the people before you begin have a
reminders when before before today when
was the last time you play blind for
chess I don't know when I normally don't
play blindfold I do I've done some shows
like for chess 24 like someone tablets
and stuff like that but
maybe like three four months ago okay so
alright well he's got some practice in
now but let's see if you can make it
happen Nick okay hey BAE any time cd4
a six
Knight c3 knight c6 wing III Knight f6
Bishop c4
for those viewers who haven't watched
Nick a lot he loves to play these
Sicilian games do you study stealing a
lot don't you that's right he's he's
he's pretty he's pretty humble humble
for a kid this should be 7g six
nick is over there trying to be in
Quetta was Bishop over there in the
castle but uh
Hebei Bishop g7 okay didn't didn't care
about the didn't care about the on their
it takes me five Queen takes a eight
nine takes me five
like I said to Kyle being being down
some key pieces against the Grandmaster
is not a big deal you can always stack
someone herself castles
97
you didn't really care if you didn't
have the for it it's gonna attack your
queen queen c8 the night d5
all right Knight takes d5 3 3 minutes 30
seconds 3 minutes 30 seconds for Pepe
about a little under two and a half
minutes for Nick Nick is in time trouble
down pieces we'll see how he reacts you
know for somebody for such a young age I
he is he he does take his time he likes
to make sure all the bases are covered
he's like a teenage old man night before
teen b7
see three
and there goes those two pawns starting
to march on day two
this game is like getting getting old
it's like you see the pawns coming light
like your hair is starting to fall out
but like you can't do anything to stop
it you know
slowly marching on for all those here's
a see here it takes you one Queen takes
you one Queen takes e4
Queen b7 matter three
rook b8 okay
of course you saw the threat it says
it's like if you see a fire you're
supposed to if you're on fire
there's no stop drop and roll that's if
he sees a threat he's gonna protect six
h3 and March and pawns on the other side
for all you Game of Thrones fans out
there this is what they call winter is
coming winter is coming
h6 Queen d2
our boy Nick is not doing too bad here
materialized only down one pond but you
know d5 I can't look in a sideways I'm
looking at saw sideways it's it's hard
for me Queen a six
and for all you viewers out there you
only here around for this but if Nick
and loses he has to do 20 push-ups
that's basically you know I didn't agree
to that it's you you work here you agree
to everything Queen a one check
mighty one
g5
Queen a5
can you two
Queen a8
Quincy six
nigt
you're almost at a minute yeah you one
minute one minute
yeah you got 28 seconds f 592 nice
already on G to F for less than 30
seconds for Nick Knight g4 f g3 Queen e8
Queen d3 now Queen D okay kingi to Queen
takes G for Queenie for check Queen
takes
man he would be 5 Kiku intense time
probably here king f7 at King f6
King f5 d 5 before rig d8 king b3 rook
c8 III b5 you flagged and there is the
flag on Nixa man this uh what's the time
well pepper you huh me follow you had
like 10 seconds left
good job Nick you want to say a few
words before you walk out of here in
shame no all right we get it you're not
even but you're not even gonna set up
the board what is this for all you kids
out there good sportsmanship we stopped
the board was there even a handshake
what was that oh my god come on alright
Nick if you yet sin sin the next oh and
here we go here we go yeah we are joined
by chess club manager Jonathan and Ron's
you guys probably remember him from
being the winner of intense chest the
other night how do you feel today
Jonathan well I'm sort of I think people
maybe have been taking the wrong
approach today you know you're not
they're not trying to beat this guy
maybe I could take this guy on maybe I
got a few tricks to swindle the guy
relaying the move I think that's that's
probably the right approach here good
plan good plan a B how do you feel right
now you've been through or like what
four games now yeah it's been tough and
now Jonathan is quite a strong player we
played a lot of blitz games and he
managed to beat me instead of them so
let's see what happens viewers I will
make sure Nick does his twenty push-ups
don't worry about that he will do it and
let's go ahead and get started on in the
next game
alright here we go have you any time
a 6 e 4 C 5 e 5 98 96 d4c d4 Knight
takes e5 Knight d5 a 6 Bishop takes f6
97 light a fire
hmm we see five
d6
so queen bee 496
we'll be free
Knight f2d 4 we should takes Knight
takes d4 very intense game so far let's
see what the time is here heavy has 3 15
gonna be 6
all right for all those who do not
remember Jonathan's skill of ratings
well we're right under two thousand he
did beat a national master the other day
in intense chest to win it all and that
was pretty exciting so let's see if he
can pull it through here against the GM
Queen c6
we shall d3
Bishop e6
efore
there's so much tension in here just uh
everybody has to heather has her blood
flowing in exchange man this is uh
alright
Queens been attacked what is he gonna to
Queen c7 Castle
rook b8
Group A to E one
b5e five right mmm we'll take d4 that
was the trick
oh there we go some tactics time dang it
b takes e4
okay
we should take c4
some very vicious pins here by Pepe it's
like a boxing you're just like pinned on
the ropes what you gonna do
a five
it's okay Jonathan we defy I've been
saying to everybody today being down a
piece against Jim is not not a big deal
not a big deal no word yet
Queeny 7
we're still waiting on this h5
rook d8 about a minute left for Pepe
minutes 34 Jonathan h4
[Music]
f5
Brooke f.2d one Rock age six
okay about 30 seconds left wing GA check
three second left for Pepe one minute
one minute thirty for Jonathan King
takes King e75 rib d7 to d5 g5 g 4g h3
rook g 6d for h1 rook f6 flag ah and
there's a flag flags down for Pepe so
jonathan still had a little over a
minute left wow that was pretty exciting
the game anything when I don't anything
you want to say yeah it's pretty easy I
think I took the right approach i text
this guy he was playing a little bit
slow he kind of kind of hinted you there
you did this you did well you played a
lot better than me obviously even
without looking but in the end I knew I
could play faster than this guy that was
our battle plan by Jonathan's Ron's what
do you think about that heavy well I
think the angle was pretty pretty
complicated because the opening is is
pretty tough and then so I had to spend
a lot of time over there and then you
know it was tough at the end game so I
was with a clear advantage but then you
know I was running out of time so what
to do well there is that is the first
loss for pepper today we have now it's
the record of four and one pretty pretty
good pretty good
for all the future contestants I think
are the main plan is to go after Caleb
gossin here all right make sure yeah
make sure he flagged make sure pivot and
him flags that's the whole goal of this
situation well thank you very much for
joining joining us Jonathan we will look
forward to the next opponent all right
and now right after the manager of the
club we have assistant manager of the
Chess Club
Dennis LaRue coming in as the sixth
challenge
this way yep come on this way he is part
of the same team Jonathan is who is
basically keeps the club running
functioning perfectly any any words you
want to say before the match begins John
good luck I like how Jonathan has
started made the strategy about
attacking Caleb I think I'm gonna follow
suit there you have it now we have a
battle plan same battle plan let's see
if Dennis can pull it off all right any
time you're ready pepper okay e4 d4
so rating wise Dennis is slightly lower
than Jonathan so we're gonna distract
Pepe a little bit so we can give Dennis
a shot here you know the your battle
plan rests on you
the Japs have frequent xf3 you fell for
the trick you fell for the trick here we
go night of 6 1987
we shall see for Pepe just too confused
a little more next game you're gonna
start playing a black pieces and see how
you do
it should be six castles and Pepe is
slightly up on time
so battle pan can still still read
resume you said Queen f3 right okay
Knight b6
Bishop d3 and heaven while you're
thinking got another surprise for you so
next guest next player you're gonna give
time off and he sighs like B to D 5 B to
D 5 okay so a three
see five
so for all of us in the future we're
gonna see four we're gonna have our very
own Caleb Ghassan over here to play as
well you know what it's fun I might join
in you never know I might have to cheat
with my phone you know with the engine
ninety-seven
a little under three and a half minutes
for Pepe - what is it - 34 - 50 for
Dennis and Dennis is falling off the
track for his battle Bishop takes e5
shup d4 rook to d1
it's slightly not fair for a 5v5
right
sometimes it's not fair for our club
employees to play play this game against
Pepe so we might we might get somebody
to try their hand again at this see if
they actually win
[Music]
all right well Genesis plan is
definitely falling through age six yeah
down on time which means his opponents
officially not Caleb anymore it's now
he's straight up playing Peppa he's gay
he's keeping he's getting destroyed a
little bit
alright alright Knight takes e5 this is
and this is our first shot at doing this
blindfold banter blitz so let us know
how you hug what you think of it info
SMU is chess club org any new shows you
want to see any suggestions you want to
submit also info a st. Louis chess club
org six we had a couple of viewers say
that they were gonna write write a
little short essay about how how good of
a job I'm doing I'm still waiting on
that so if that's you send it in and
Pepe still doing good on time a little
has a little over 130 and less than a
minute for our man Dennis LaRue he's
let's keep it pop positive he's doing
okay he's he is actually not
Bishop takes c3 Queen takes b3
oh yeah rook takes c3 alright and we
have and Pepe has lost the position of
the mind it's a little bit so let's kiss
he has he has he's up one time he can
still get the image back at that d1 rook
e1 f - g - h - right i'm paul takes up
and there were so dennis actually did go
on its go through his battle plan of
trying to defeat caleb because that's
basically what's happening right now
from c v to III black did not play Queen
takes III he played Queen takes b3 okay
alright let's let's start it up let's
start form from this my pawn is some c4
I'm a yeah
okay so Queen takes me three rook takes
b3
ninety-five
rook takes a three about 30 seconds 30
seconds left for both players
III f4 Knight takes e4 Knight d2 takes a
tree Knight takes b1 you too
rook e8 King f7 roof takes rook to King
King d7 Keinath took in f3 primo oh and
there's the flag for Denison we have
three seconds left for Pepe Wow that was
basically the fastest hand wins so man
we have we okay we had a we had a bit of
miscommunication in the game we had time
trouble for both sides III and then
Queen III Queen takes Queen takes c3 and
then I thought you said Queen takes III
that's all right it happens all the time
Dennis what do you think about that game
that was a lot of fun yeah
miscommunication B sounds a lot like E
okay they both have the same vowel and
[Laughter]
so we will try our best to keep the
miscommunication on a minimum and while
we'll welcome in our next guest welcome
welcoming another chess club associate
we have Brittany
oh this is oh I didn't know about this
so this is Brittany's first official
game okay Brittany any any first words
you heard it
let's give a little prayer give a little
prayer so we're gonna so we're actually
gonna switch up your you switch ups yeah
you're playing white you're playing
black you're playing yeah so we're gonna
give Britain's Britain his first time
playing we're gonna give her time odds
and peace odds which means so do you
want to do Queen Queen odds you want to
do Queen knots okay so we give Brittany
Queen osprey no Quinn over here so then
we're gonna give her time on as well how
about let's say five three we do that
now we do that key okay lucky
okay sounds good so as you so viewers we
have time outs two minutes less for Pepe
and Queen odds so we'll see if Britney
can win this game okay Annie that's
right that's right she's a new player so
we're gonna give her some odds all right
any time you're ready Brittany you can
start it off Knight f3 c 5 d 4
d4c takes e4 Knight takes d4 g6
ninety to ninety to ninety x d4
Bishop d3 so that's a that's the second
time for any tried it to be legal
majestic just to throw people off just
throw people off the second the last
game you got to make it count okay Sonia
look a talker here no 0 that night c4
Knight c4 okay not up c3 that's tactical
she's doing it she's doing on purpose
a 5v5 okay D takes e5 Knight takes e5
Bishop III to be eight
all right and it looks like they're
about this
Brittney's c3 bernie has won the battle
plan of before playing playing against
me takes d1 looks like the piece odds
are gone so we're gonna look at time
well she's still up I slightly by a
little bit Bishop b4 I bet it's because
you viewers didn't pray for Brittany
like she asked you guys suck c19 take c4
Brook be one night text me - Brooke
takes B 2 root X t1 K F - Mitchell takes
me to I wonder what kind of person
Britney is she going to type to resign
where is she gonna play to the bitter
end like jonathan did she just say she
doesn't give up
she doesn't give up
[Music]
[Music]
looks like they're about the same on
time minute 30 left each takes b7 so now
a fish bishop c1 check so we're talking
about fish Lee P thoughts and time odds
are both gone at this point that was
again a tactical trying to psyche
somebody out you know that's like a
feint in boxing you just that's how it
is that's how it is
we're still trying to play Kaleb at this
point we're trying to make him sort up
qe4 rook a to d4 chick
Keeney father Bishop f4 oh there we go
and that it's a-ok and that is the end
of Brittany's first game would you would
you think about that it was exhilarating
I'm a little anxious but it was good
nonetheless thoughts on that paper yeah
it was a lot of fun and she tried and
then she she kept fighting until the end
that's what you have to do in chess yeah
there you have it fight until the bitter
end all right for all you kids out there
I see a lot of kids nowadays just just
resigning in the middle of the game and
we don't want it okay well perfect so
this is now since Kayla's been teens
skittles to the mover all day he wants
to get in on the action so he's gonna be
playing you how do you feel about
playing but you want to keep on playing
black so Caleb's been Kayla is basically
what you were like seven points under
becoming a national master autocorrect
nine points so he's gonna try to get
that soon and we're gonna see he's been
preparing a lot so we're gonna see if he
can actually make it happen do you wanna
do you prefer playing the wider black
pieces
oh all right Caleb has chosen to play
the black pieces which means Petra is
gonna be playing white again and now we
switch to assistant manager Denis Uluru
as the mover for Pepe and any any words
you want to say before the match begins
Caleb
okay quiet and Stern that's how he is
well we'll see if you can make it happen
with no no pieces no time ah since he is
pretty high level in tears my rating
we're gonna play even game all right
Pepe anytime you're ready okay d4 g6 c4
Bishop g7 Knight d7 b4 b4 and a key play
e5
we shall be to night h6 castles
h3
f6 Knight f7
Quincy to
just at first glance it was c6 Queen c7
rook e8 rook e8 right you said okay okay
okay use your best one
all right a quick glance it looks like
Kayla was trying to do the same battle
strategy of planing trying to playing as
Dennis high on time so he let's see if
we can out Bishop h6 so we can out time
Dennis
Knight takes h6
before
b4 night f7
see five
you don't have to keep I'm sorry uh DC D
takes e5 Knight f6 Knight b3
and Kayla's following the battle plan
perfectly he is up almost what is it two
minutes almost 1 minute have a has just
over two and a half and caleb has three
in almost four Wow okay so if he
continues take advantages lag Bishop d7
rook ad8 sorry got it
Bishop c8 rookie do you want got it rook
takes D to rook takes D - okay
rook d8 rook takes the eight
Queen takes Queen you to Queen d2 Knight
d4 f3
right slowly but surely time is heavy is
gaining on some time he's still down he
only has a little over two minutes and
caleb has two minutes 50 seconds so
battle plan is still in play
King g7
ninety-eight
Bishop to d3
Bishop e6 AC
all right 146 for g5 92
night be free night be three you said
might be free right yes night xp3 Bishop
takes b3
Bishop f7g 396 Bishop c4 we got some
fairly quick moves from Caleb semi quick
moves from dent Dennis so when we see
what the battle plans coming to play 120
left for Pepe two minutes for Caleb so
he is doing well
however he needs to keep up the pace in
order to keep up with the battle plan ID
for Knight takes eetu in a draw offer
draw offer came from Pepe and acceptance
of the offer once we see Wow Wow I mean
so seconds you thought this was my most
successful moment over the chessboard
ever these are the strongest moves I've
ever played in my life I just want to
add that was completely disgusting ez
flag this is the slowest hands at the
Chess Club well that was our first
blindfold blitz banter if you want to
see it again please let us know or else
we're going to try some new things maybe
we'll come back to this and as always
thank you for joining us on our stream
hopefully you can join us tomorrow at 3
p.m. for my calm
places people and that's gonna be a fun
time all right well thank you very much
and have a good day this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club